Ray Stevenson's most punishing role was
in Lexi Alexander's Punisher war zone
released in 2008 this reboot boast blood
guts and more R-rated violence in the
average superhero movie Stephenson
dazzles as Frank Castle embodying the
Vigilante from the brutal Punisher comic
book
series see you in hell I see you
anywhere near hell I'll kick your ass up
unfortunately Punisher war zone neither
lit up the box office nor inspired
critics to get skull tattoos on their
biceps but despite the film's
underwhelming financial Inc iCal
performance it eventually became a cult
classic in a chat with Stevenson for the
action Elite writer David J Moore
expressed his dismay that the actor
never had a chance to return to the role
of Castle Stevenson agreed saying so was
I write in and tell them that I would in
a heartbeat go back I love the storyline
in the comic books that it was based on
it could definitely do with the sequel
sadly this never happened as Netflix
rebooted Punisher as a series with
Walking Dead Star John Bernthal as the
titular character